excellent we're live
thank you for joining damorato
glad to be here
we're very grateful to be featuring you
on the show
it's been fun
seeing your
content
the supra mundane
dhamma
it's been awesome
yeah
looking forward to
continuing to
playfully unpack
the dhamma and in service to all of our
fellow
viewers
that are
aiming to decrease their suffering and
increase their happiness and well-being
and peace
well
instead of increasing and decreasing
just in this moment you just throw it
out
[Music]
there's no fixation on getting rid of
suffering or on increasing happiness you
just throw both concepts out you're just
thrown out right
that's what is that's the meaning of the
supramundane
and possibly the way to talk about it is
by starting with the pali the word
supramundane that we have been using
comes from the pali word
lokatara
and lokitara of the world loka antara
means to be above the world
now uh basically what we mean by
lokitara there
is to be above the conceptualized world
or the world that we think exists
but there's a real world that exists in
the real world is the world of our sense
the world we can see the world we can
touch the world we can bite the world
we've been
here
that kind of stuff
is all the world is to it
and yet in our educational system when
we were children we were given maps and
globes and lists of countries names and
things like that
that became a conceptualized world
and so when we're talking about lokitaro
we're not talking about
uh being above reality we're talking
about
being above our conceptualized world the
world that really doesn't exist except
between the ears
all those fluctuations of mind
oh man
concepts ideas
good bad at the identity
and the idea is just to come out of all
of that and to be in reality be in the
real world of our senses
and that way that's the super mundane
but
uh
this also is used in the sense of um
three kinds of views when the buddha
describes
the eight paul noble path in the suta
117 and the majja manikaya
he brings about it in the sense of
talk about it in three ways there are
three kinds of views of the world there
is the wrong view
the right view that is an ordinary right
you
and then there is the super mundane
right here or the lokitara the ones
above the world
this is also called noble
am i frozen on your end
you're frozen on my end
okay
i'm i'm trying to
maybe
i'm trying to figure out what the issue
is
um
let's see here
let me see if i can join from my
um from my laptop
i don't know what the issue is i haven't
had this type of a problem before
of course it's coming right at the good
time of
our intro let me see if i can join here
from my laptop
okay
[Music]
okay
all right
so we had just gotten started
talking about
where the word supramundane comes from
and why we use it
and so in in uh the suits are called the
great 40 number 117 in the major mecha
the buddha does a very very detailed but
noble description of the april noble
path
and there he starts with view
and talks about that there is wrong view
and there is right here
and basically wrong view is the
mentality of the child
that says i can get away with it i can
do anything i want to do and get away
with it
just grabbing an attachment
for my mic
okay
so
getting away with it is basically the
wrong view
uh
and
the wrong view is basically
based upon
the freedom to do
what we want to do
and what we want
anything that we want that we can't have
is
the definition of suffering or the
definition of dukkha
and
actually
the word dukkha is badly translated into
suffering a better word
we could use would be just dissatisfying
so when you want something that means
you're dissatisfied without it
and the wrong view is is that i can just
go get what i want and be satisfied
and it doesn't matter the consequences
but ordinary right view says no you
can't get away with it and we're going
to hire cops
and and and uh
get an army and but i have guards and if
that doesn't work then we'll get a
priest or two
and we're going to make sure that you
know that no matter what you can't get
away with it
this is basically religion
is ordinary right view which is saying
you can't get away with it and so they
have laws of commas heavens and hells
and all kinds of stuff
to convince the one of wrong view
that he can't get away with it
and then there is the third kind of view
the supra mundane view
the right noble view
which is that
you don't know whether you can get away
with it or not
but you need to do it through an
investigation you need to find out
really what's going on
we need to stop coming to conclusions
and concepts and uh thoughts that we
know
whether we can get away with it or not
and really take a look
transcend this i know and i don't know
into not sure let's just take another
look
so that's the uh the foundation of the
supramundane is to come away from our
attachments to our conceptualized world
so that we can draw back
and take a closer look
so that's the definition of the word
supreme mundane which actually is just
uh lokitara
and in the process of doing that one
needs to let go
of what we were talking about
that is the things that we want and
whether we can get away from it or not
or get away with it
and
just allow things to be the way that
they really are in reality the senses
that which we can see touch taste
smell
bite that kind of stuff
that's real
an example of that is neither seattle
nor vladimir putin are real
they're merely concepts
for some people seattle is real
because they're in seattle and they can
see it there they are
but most seattle is not real
okay
so
what is real
is
what is worthy of being investigated
so that we can see
really what's going on
this is a major teaching of the buddha
is this quality of not only
investigating but continually
investigating in the sense of
investigate and then investigate again
and then later investigate again
[Laughter]
glad to see you getting all comfy there
okay
so we won't um pass too much time
describing
the experience that was apparently being
had over here but the main computer
froze and shut off
and
had a temporary laptop fix and now the
main computer is back on
and
i have heard bits and pieces of what you
were sharing
and there was a lot of profundity that
you were unpacking along the way
and i would like to resume at a place
where i felt like i was still
hearing what you were saying
which was that
the the active mind
that
is constantly
fluctuating
in discursive thinking from idea to idea
to concept to concept is always
separating by name and form and shape
and so there's never the
um the stopping of those fluctuations of
mind to be able to feel what is
underlying everything
um
and then there's a perpetual
investigation into
well self-inquiry who am i
also
inquiry into what exists when
there is not this discursive thinking
what is left
and reality reality yeah
cool so if you want to pick it up from
from there i would love to continue
playing there and then we'll see if we
can get to some of what you were saying
in these last couple of minutes as i was
switching
technology
okay
let's put it this way
then over
a period of 2500 years since the time of
the buddha there has been a number of
episodes uh that have brought about some
changes
and you can actually see how those
things evolved
an example of that is the concept of
meta
and the brahma biharas was an old
concept before the buddha and that that
uh
got kind of tacked on
as part of his teaching
and that the concept then of may all
beings be happy
is what within about 500 years evolved
into
the bodhisattva ideal of
i've got to wait at the door of
enlightenment until all beings be
enlightened and then i can be
enlightened too
now that's obviously ridiculous
it's obviously ridiculous
because it's almost as ridiculous as the
mormons uh
uh
baptizing people who are already dead
so
uh the bodhisattva ideal is ridiculous
in the way that
uh if
one has no role models
in other words there are no enlightened
beings
then how are all the other beings going
to know what enlightenment is and in
fact that's the problem with the western
buddhism is none of the people in the
west have even a clue about what
enlightenment actually is
they've got concepts about it
and those concepts are normally based in
the culture that they were raised in
which has a lot of christian influence
to it
okay so
uh
this time
evolved
through the bodhisattva period into
later the tantric period
and that tantric period basically talks
about it in the sense of being at one
with all of reality
[Music]
and that um
that becoming all of reality or being
one with reality means that you're part
of the show which means that you are the
show and this is where
heavy duty mystical magical thinking was
brought into buddhism
into the teachings of the buddha and so
it has gone through
evolutions of devolvement
and that you could talk about that
development was that it evolved from
uh freedom from religion
into a religion
that was the evolution of teachings of
the buddha over the past 2500 years is
it devolved from a response or an action
or freedom from religion
into being a religion but not exactly
basically what happened was is that a a
religion grew up around the original
teachings
almost in the way of making the
protection
so everything that people hear about
buddhism in the west
is the buddhism the religion of buddhism
that grew up
around the real teachings of the buddha
almost like a protection
think of it as a gilded box that's
highly highly jeweled
and very specialized and everybody wants
that box but nobody's opened the box to
find out what's in it
and the real teachings of the buddha is
inside the box not the box
itself but the issue is is that
everybody loves the box because the
interior of the box is not very
interesting to most people in fact you
can say you could go so far as to say
the
inside of the box is empty
soon you top
but uh there's a very practical way of
doing that in the sense that we do have
to open the box
to recognize that the box is merely a
container that the religion of buddhism
is merely a religion
and that
we could go so far also is to say then
that religion
is
the answer
that people have to
barbarism or
let us say
when children are born if they are
raised without any rights rules rituals
or anything then we will not be able to
have a society we'll just have a bunch
of barbarians
and so society
has been brought about
by having some order and some rules
these rules then
uh
have to have an order to them
and so as i was saying in uh originally
the ordinary right view
says you can't get away with it we're
going to have some rules here and if you
break those rules you're going to get
punished
so we talk about it then and this is
actually
the
law of comma
now the law of comma exists in every
religion
in some religions they call it a god
i call it the comma machine
now what is the comma machine or what do
people think of comma is that
if you do right you'll get good results
and if you do
uh
wrong you'll get bad results this is
actually the teachings
that were common in the time of the
buddha
and that's what religion is all about
in the sense that if you do good you'll
get into heaven and if you do bad
you'll get
you'll go to hell
but in some religions there's an escape
clause
it's called mercy or grace or something
it's a get out of hell free card
a lot of people think that oh if i get
my get out of hell free card now i can
go back and do wrong and get away with
it
that's called hypocrisy
and
religions are filled with hypocrisy when
they have that issue of
you can get away with it because you can
get forgiveness
but the noble dharma the supra-mundane
dhamma
comes out of all of those concepts
of heavens and hells and future
results of current actions
and so the buddha actually was not
against
comma in the sense that there are some
good actions that do lead to good
results if you're
thirsty and you drink water
you are
a quest of your thirst that's a very
good clear example of
good action giving good results
if however the bottle is full of arsenic
and you drink that that you will have
different results
that's a bad action drinking arsenic
giving bad results
if we understand it that way
then we can understand that there is a
causal link
between the results
and the action
that most of the religions will have a
non-causal link it's just because you
did that later you're going to get
punished without looking at how that
action is linked
to the result
and so uh the buddha talks about it also
in the sense that uh fire
requires a fuel
that's the cause and effect relationship
right there
what fire do you know of
that has no fuel
do you know of a fire that burns without
any fuel at all
i'll give you an example of one who
where people think that the fuel exists
or the fire exists without a fuel and
that is reincarnation
reincarnation means that this person
dies now and then pops up later what's
the causal link between the two
there is no cause with me that's the
issue we cannot see one and
so
the real teaching of the buddha is much
more about causality
causality the cause and effect in fact
there's several words in it in in poly
one of idiopapa jayata which is general
causality
and then there is another word that they
talk about that is translated as a
dependent
origination
those are actually just two poly words
that mean something in the poly but when
you translate them separately it gives
you silliness
okay dependent origination the actual
poly
is a petitchi samupada or in the uh the
thai language it's petite
so the teacher samupata actually is
talking about
the cause and effect that happens in the
mind and there is a number of causes
that happen a sequence of events that
happened in the mind
and that that sequence of events
if it is ignorant
if we're not watching what we're doing
if we live by concepts
then that conceptualized thinking is
going to wind us into the position of
wanting something that we don't have
which brings us on to the four modes of
clinging that will then take us
uh or we can be then reborn into a
woeful state
so these willful states happen moment by
moment in the mind they're not some
local state that happens way off into
the future everything has a causal link
and wanting something you don't have
for instance will lead to the causal
link of becoming a hungry ghost the
prieta
right the hungry ghost somebody who
wants something and wants something and
wants something and wants something they
go around haunting their whole
environment every place they go they
keep wanting things and wanting things
and this is called the preach of the
hungry ghost
the one that i see most often in the
western world
is people are reborn as animals
what is being reborn as an animal means
you is if we're not talking about bugs
and instincts we're talking or even
reptiles we're talking about draft
animals
horses
bulls draft animals that have to do what
they're told to do donkeys
i remember seeing a donkey in india one
time where the donkey was tied to a
large um uh
looked like a small you know four or six
inch tree that was cut down to some long
pole about 30 feet long
and one was tie one the end was tied to
the donkey and the other was tied to a
millstone and the donkey went around
this big circle over and over again
while the guy put sugarcane stalks
in his mill
and out came sugarcane juice
and he sold it for 10 rupees of glass it
was warm it was out in the hot sun but
it was something to drink you i mean
that's all you had then
guess how much of that sugarcane juice
the donkey gets
the donkey's doing all the work and the
donkey don't get no juice
guess what
ibm
and um uh microsoft and uh
google and a lot of these companies have
a lot of donkeys
working for them and all of that juice
comes in in the form of corporate
earnings
and the donkey don't get none
this is how our lives are lived that the
corporate uh
crowd
uh keeps the poor poor
it keeps them thirsty you want that dog
that uh donkey thirsty
to keep him working
and so this is how the life of most of
us uh in the west live our lives we live
our lives doing what we're told to do
going along to get along
and we don't like it
that's why we call it work we call it
job nobody calls it i'm going to play
today at the office
right because it's not play he's not
enjoying he's working and not only is he
working but he already is resentful
because he knows he's not going to get
paid all that he's worth
because some portion is going to be kept
by the company
like most of it
so here we are living our lives
in woeful states of going along to get
along doing what we're told to do
and that we got used to resenting it
the trick is why don't we do what we
want to do
they're fun and profit
that's the question
we go around doing what we're told to do
and resenting it when we can in fact go
around doing what we like to do and
loving it
that's the real teaching of the buddha
right there
is that
we
uh get ourselves into a woeful state
because of the concepts
conceptualized thoughts
but if the donkey
who is walking around that
treadmill path that he's got
is actually enjoying his scenery
paying attention to the people who were
uh getting his sugar cane juice the
donkey may even ask me don't you like my
juice
maybe they'll start petting him and
he'll have a good day
but most donkeys just go around the path
over and over and over again drudgery oh
poor me i'll have a pity party i gotta
do my work and i'm not gonna get paid
so it's the attitude of us donkeys
they keep doing what we're told to do
not enjoying our lives
and it's all just a matter of attitude
basically what we mean by attitude here
is
the pali word is sama sankapa and it's a
feature of the echo noble path
with not only right view to open our
eyes and look and pay attention to see
what's going on
but the next item is is that
we have to remember
to pay attention we have to remember to
look at what we're doing
and that memory then is the most
important skill to be developed
that's called the skill of sati
to wake up wakey wakey saty is very
close to the word voting
or bowed just to wake up
and we can actually use that in
contraposition to what we would normally
think of
as daydreaming and most of us go around
daydreaming
all the time
what does that mean living in a
conceptualized world daydreaming
and we could come out of that daydream
and be in reality
if we can remember
to wake up
and look at what's going on
but often when we wake up and look at
what's going on we recognize that all i
was now that i'm waking up i recognize i
was in conceptual thoughts and most of
the conceptualized thinking is actually
critical thinking
critical thinking means i like this i
don't like that this is good this is bad
let's improve this this house is okay
but i need a bigger house i need a tower
i need to name trump on it i need this
that and the other thing and so
we our conceptualizations keep us in
suffering because we want thanks over
and over again we either want
to make an improvement
or we want to destroy
so you can actually see that
conceptualized thinking of criticism or
critical thinking
actually is the source for the second
noble truth
the cause of suffering
what is the cause of suffering
greed
ill will
and delusion
what we mean by that is the delusion is
the critical thoughts of
this is good and i want it or this is
bad and i don't
i'm just putting the teaching of the
buddha in a more
um uh westernized uh language
so that we can understand that it's in
the mind that causes this stuff that
greed is a concept of critical thinking
and we can't when we recognize that
critical thinking
we can come out of it
and start having nurturing thoughts
instead
that when we were very babies when we
were 10 infants
every one of us got a great deal of
loving care
we were nurtured
any child who was not nurtured probably
will not survive and if he does survive
you'll survive with very heavy uh
psychological problems but most all of
us are nurtured when we're infants
and that nurturing
stays in in deer until about the age of
four or five or six
and that's when we're given the abcs at
the one two three and we're told to go
to school to pick up a clothes and uh
put your cell phone down and do your
homework etc etc and that's when the
child is introduced into the critical
world of our society
and
criticism becomes the predominant and
nurturing takes the backseat
sometimes it's even left out the back
end
and so what actual the practice of
anapanasati would be
would be taking these parts of the
eightfold and oval path
this ability to wake up to pay attention
to what the mind is doing
to recognize that much of the thoughts
are critical thoughts and we can come
out of those critical thoughts and start
nurturing
and having nurturing thoughts instead
to nurture ourselves
and
by doing so we're removing unwholesome
thoughts
of wanting things
wanting improvements
and uh coming into the realization
through nurturing that everything is
actually okay
i mean
look around the room the room that
you're in is safe there's no crocodiles
there's no alligators there's no
cops coming in
uh no swat team
no problems at all and yet many people
will have thoughts that lead to fear
but the reality is is that there's
nothing to fear right now
almost always that's true almost always
the things that we are afraid of
are because we remember tragic
situations in the past
and then we plan for those tragic
situations in the future to where right
now is okay
that's another way of looking at it in
the sense of the lokitara to be
above the world
means that if we are in
reality
then we're out of the concepts
reality is what's happening right now
and right now
through the senses is quite nice
this next breath is a really nice breath
the breeze is a really nice freeze
everything is okay right now in the
present moment
well let's look at it in the sense of
this present moment here and now
here is
the reality
then you can say well how big is my
reality well it's as far as i can see i
can see out to the end of the road
or out to the end of the drive and then
i can see a little bit of the road and
then i don't see any more because of all
of the trees and whatnot which means
that things that are beyond my site are
really not in reality
i can remember
i've been down that road but now when i
go down that road in my mind i'm not in
reality actually going down the road and
then
conceptualizing my mind you see
and so if we learn to live in reality
reality right here right now is safe
so now
that we've defined what is here we can
also look at now because anything that's
in the past is gone it's dead it doesn't
exist
and everything
is yet to be
and it probably won't be when it does
come the way that we thought that we
wanted it to be when we were thinking
about it in concepts
in the past
so the whole teaching of the buddha is
is to come into the present moment
coming out of a conceptualized mind
and just be here
now and only have input that's real
input
rather than mental input
that's why the buddha talks about it in
in the
case of six sensors
we have eyes ears
tongue
nose and touch then we have that sixth
sense which is
thinking
now not all thinking is talking thinking
there is other kinds of thinking going
on
one kind of way of spending thinking is
in the senses if you're actually looking
at something that's happening you're not
doing a whole lot of thinking about it
you think about it after
you look at it
while you're actually watching something
uh the mind moments that were spent is
actually incenses
another way that we can spend mind
moments is in actually feelings
which is actually part of our senses
anyway now we're feeling senses
but most of the time we spend in um
not in reality we spend in mental
concepts
thinking
and so
when when we have those thoughts we
generally have thoughts about the past
and about the future
if we think about the past normally the
things that we remember
are the tragedies we don't remember the
really good things there's a lot of
really good stuff happening and we don't
pay much attention to it we only kind of
pay attention to tragedies
an example would be that little billy is
uh drawing with crayons on the wall in
his bedroom and his mom comes in
and instead of looking at what he's
doing she freaks out about the wall and
the paint and landlords and all of this
kind of stuff
and punishes him
for writing on the wall he'll remember
that
she could have taken a different tact
she could have said my this drawing is
wonderful and marvelous i'm going to go
get you a paint set
but she didn't and he could have been a
rembrandt
but now that he's had that tragic
situation of writing on the wall and
having to clean it and being punished
and all of that kind of stuff he winds
up not being a very good artist
doesn't use his hands much
he makes that kind of decision when he's
really early and then he doesn't
develop the motor skills that he needs
so these are the kind of tragedies that
happened throughout childhood one after
another after another that put together
how we can see things and how we look at
it
so that when we're adults
we begin to remember the things that
happened in the past and we're always
going to wind up remembering something
bad that happened
because we paid attention to what was
bad was happening we weren't paying much
attention to all the good stuff
this is actually instinctual behavior
we are we are actually wired that way
it's called the self-preservation
instinct that when the self present or
the organism is in danger
then
um
oh that ties so perfectly with dependent
origination the self-preservation
instinct because that's the very that's
the very first link
is ignorance or knowledge
and
that for very first link is that
self-preservation instinct is are you
totally okay
with no self with anata
and if you're totally if you're totally
okay with emptiness if you're totally
okay with infinity if you're totally
okay with no self with anata
then you have
only right action emerges perpetually
because you're always coming from
oneness you're always coming from love
you're always coming from no self you're
always coming from reality and you're
not you can remember if you can remember
but remember we've already been uh wired
to our habit systems
and we were not raised
by buddhas we were raised by
families who perpetuate the family's
uh problems so all the uh the dukkha
that comes with the family
is passed on to the child
many many examples of that one of them
is that they know that a child who is
raised in a household that is um uh
prone for domestic violence when that
child grows up and is living in another
household as an adult that household too
will be prone to domestic violence
train up a child in the way he should go
and when he is old he'll do what he's
told
that's
the hurting instinct again or um
going along to get along or
uh being a member of the pack
this is how we
basically we operate as human beings
this is that we follow the herd we have
in fact that hurting instinct is part of
the self-preservation instinct
in the sense that those in the middle of
the herd if you've got a herd of wilbur
bees and you've got lions around than
the ones in the middle of the herd the
safest and the stragglers are in danger
of lunch
of being lunch
so that's our hurting instinct and we do
that as children we pick up on that
and go along to get along
because we're looking for safety
security from that self-preservation
instinct and i must also say that it's
mislabeled
that the guys who came up with the
terminology for self-preservation
instinct would have been more corrupt if
they had said organism
preservation instinct
because it's actually the organism
that's being
perpetuated
and when i mean that organism i'm
talking about the body
the feelings
the mind and the objects of the mind the
satyapatana the satyapatana the human
body the form and all of its feelings
are real
and so
that organism there does not necessarily
have a self or a center or a soul
but it does have
that instinct for preservation
so whenever the mind perceives danger
the self-preservation instinct is going
to come up get in gear and try to
protect the self from danger
and often that danger doesn't exist
it's not real
or we create it
through the perception of the danger
several examples of that the 14 year old
boy is walking down the hall in high
school and around the corner he sees the
bully and his two friends
coming down the hall
and he sees the bully and he freezes
he's afraid of the bully
naturally the bullet is going to pick on
him
the other way to handle that is he sees
the bully coming around the corner with
his two friends
he can go in one of two directions
either in the direction the bully is
going now he's ahead of him or he can
take off in the opposite direction and
pass the bully right by if the bully
says something you say i'm in a hurry
now i've got to go bye
but no
because he was afraid he stood there
and he got bullied
more than likely that's going to happen
the second time now he's in the habit of
getting bullied
and he didn't have to get bullied at all
he doesn't have to hit the bully he can
just
take a hike
[Music]
so
this is how we learn
that uh we often create
our dangers
through the perceptions of fear
and we pick up these perceptions of
fears
because we find as children so much to
be afraid of
and we continue along as adults being
afraid of this that and the other thing
in fact that's what society is really
all about humans have built a society
in order to take us out of the jungle
we build cities
for safety and yet all of these
all these jungle humans come into the
city
and when they come into the city for
safety
they drain their jungle with them that's
why they call it a concrete jungle
the humans have made the jungle
and we make it with our fear
we see jungle when in fact there's no
jungle there if we would pay attention
and look at things reality-wise in this
present moment we could recognize no
we're safe here there's no problem
and so this is what we need to actually
practice
this is the practice of anapanasaki
again is to take this right view
this right uh sati to wake up
and the right effort to change the kind
of thinking that we have from
critical thinking into nurturing
thinking
which means that
the kind of thoughts we're having are
nurturing thoughts they're wholesome
thoughts completely wholesome thoughts
thoughts about everything's all right
everything is okay
not a worry in the world
everything's all right everything is
fine
nothing to do no place to go
this
spring comes and the grass grows by
itself
[Music]
this is wholesome thinking
and we need to practice that so that we
can get ourselves into the very shape
that you're in right now wouldn't you
like wouldn't you have a marvelous life
if you run around in the position that
you're in right now
so
getting ourselves into that state
is something that's quite valuable to do
over and over and over again we work to
get the mind in a really really good
state
and once we get good at getting the mind
into a good state we begin to gain
confidence i can do this
i can
come into this state of well-being
then that's what brings on that fourth
element of the eight pull noble path
sama sankapa right attitude
the attitude of a winner the attitude i
can do this
but in fact the buddha says
that the first
knowledge or the first wisdom
on the path which means the first step
of the noble path
a lot of people talk about that
especially in the stream entry what's
the stream entry well the first step
of getting on the path is the knowledge
that no matter what happens no matter
how obstructed the mind gets
the student can throw those thoughts out
of the mind
and see things as they really are
to come to the present moment when you
know that you can do that no matter what
that's the first step of the path
you have that confidence the confidence
of i can handle this
whatever comes by
i can handle it
now this eye that i'm using is merely a
um a linguistic
um
convenience
that we don't have to say i can handle
it it's uh
it's the ad it's an attitude we're
talking about a can-do attitude
that in fact in some cultures you've
heard it talked about uh in the in the
sense of hold my beer have you ever
heard that expression
hold my beard which means i'm going to
go take care of this situation i can
handle this
all right
so this is the way that we have with the
attitude of the can-do attitude the
can-do means that no matter what kind of
pity party no matter what kind of anger
what kind of feelings that i have i can
change those feelings
i can come out of that and bring the
mind back into a really really good
state
so this is the practice of anapanasati
is over and over and over again
remembering to wake up to take a look
throw the unwholesome thoughts out of
the mind and then take
a power what do they call it uh uh
a victory lap that's the word right have
that victory left have that
i got it kind of feeling
got this one
can do
so that's the attitude and when we get
those four things together
the right uh view right sati waking up
right effort
and for the beginner there's going to be
some effort but later it gets really
easy especially when the attitude gets
really strong
and with right attitude together that
brings about what is called right
unification of mind
the right unification of mind means now
the mind is together now the mind is
whole it may not stay that way but right
now it's good to go
it's fit for work
it's ready for the job
this uh
right unification of mind in the pali is
called sama
area
samati
now the word samati
actually in this case is meaning that
we're gathering the factors together
this is not concentration concentration
is actually removing factors
that are needed
my my uh
example is um
frozen concentrated orange juice
does anybody drink frozen concentrated
orange juice
no
they take the water out of it and freeze
it for transportation purposes
but when you get the orange juice home
what do you do you make it samati by
putting the water back in it
you make it whole and complete
so concentrated orange juice is not
somatic orange juice
and yet so many people are trying to
practice up a meditation to build up
concentration
which is basically just working too hard
this is actually a piece of cake this is
easy peasy it's the easiest thing in the
world it's not hard to do
just cheer up that's all you have to do
lighten up
let go
but we have to remember to let go we
have to remember to brighten up we have
to remember to gladden the mind to make
it bright
and when we brighten the mind and we do
that over and over and over again we get
the idea that we can do this no matter
what
i can handle anything
so
that's it that's all there is to it
actually we could say then that there's
two skills to learn
one is the the skill of learning to get
into
this marvelous state
and then the second skill is to maintain
that marvelous state
to put on to be on guard
to make sure that unwholesome thoughts
are not coming back into the mind
so the teachings of the buddha is
actually quite simple but you can see
that it's been
a huge huge religion has been built
around it uh a case
actually the real teaching of the buddha
is quite dangerous
i mean if everybody had the attitude
that we were talking about right now the
gdp would fall apart
yeah
yeah if everybody was satisfied if i
don't need anything i don't want
anything i don't go shopping nobody goes
shopping nobody buys anything
because we're content and comfortable
with what we have
a whole lot of people have already been
up two three four putting you to work
they're going to be unhappy if you quit
and just hang out and enjoy your life
they want you to go back to work they
want to make some money off of you
right so that's dangerous that actually
happened
buddhism was wiped out in india took him
a couple of hundred years killed about a
hundred million people
but the brahmins and the moguls together
they got the job done
they wiped it out
guess what no they didn't
no they didn't what happens if you um
uh have a handful of jello and you
squeeze it really tight
it takes out all over the place
well that's what happened to buddhism it
just leaked out all over the place
thailand burma
sri lanka
nepal
tibet
china
korea japan
cambodia
vietnam i think it covered them all now
and so it was dispersed
but it was also dispersed in a way now
so that it
became kind of secret
in the time of the buddha it was
absolutely open
but it became kind of secret there's
another reason to keep it secret and
that is is that if someone who holds
wrong view
and then takes on ordinary right view
thinking that i can't get away with it
because i'll go to hell or the cops will
stop me or something like that
when he's introduced to uh super mundane
right view
the possibility of him falling back into
wrong view is very high
so we have to introduce right noble view
and the right noble dhamma in a way
that it invites people to come out of
their magical thinking
into the real reality rather than coming
out of their magical thinking and then
start doing harm that they didn't do
because of their magical thinking
so these are the dangers
and for that reason
the teachings came to the point of
that the student had to write ask the
right question to the right teacher at
the right time
for that student to get
the dharma
other than that all he's going to get is
buddhist religion
many monks will ordain and stay
ordained as monks
and never learn the real teachings of
the buddha
but all throughout history there has
been
that noble dhamma that has been hidden
away
and uh i know for sure that it's been
hidden away in places that i've i've
known of especially laos
burma excuse me allows cambodia and
thailand because they've spent quite a
lot of time with monks from those three
traditions
and each one of those traditions has the
noble teaching of the dhamma without
having the connections
with the others basically what i'm
saying is is that one time when i first
was introduced to vika bhutadasa i
thought very highly of him as if he were
the only one who really knew the dhamma
later on i found out that oh no the
early history of bhikkhu buddhadasa was
how he connected up with the other
nobles
but what happened was back in the 1930s
after he had been a monk for about 10
years he was in bangkok studying
pali
very deep into the poly studies and he
was invited to give public talks
and he started giving public talks and
he started teaching the noble dharma
some of the people in the audience
didn't like what he was saying
because they had ordinary view
and so they made some complaints and it
wound up him being brought up on the
charges of trying to
uh break apart the sangha
to destroy it
this is in the quality is called sangha
decessor
which meant that
in bangkok there was a huge trial
and vic kagudasa had to defend and he
had the pie and the uh
the sutas to defend himself with
but unbeknownst to him he had some
friends on that uh
as part of the judge board
but in fact the second professor
requires 20 monks
we're talking about herding cats we have
nine uh supreme court justices well for
the month is 20.
they seem to need 20 months to do all
kinds of things to have an ordination or
to have a uh a consecration of a temple
to make a place a watt
and other things like this
what happened in that trial was is that
there was an immense
literature search
brought about
and the conclusion was and the trial
ended with bhikkhu buddhadasa was
teaching the wrong thing at the right
things he was teaching the absolute
right dharma
to the wrong people
that the sangha wanted to keep the
actual real teachings of the buddha with
the sangha and vika buddhadasa didn't
want to do that he wanted to let the
real teachings of the buddha out to the
public
and he's been doing that ever since
well as i said he had some friends some
friends in really really high places
like in the royal family
and in the top group of monks there's
nobles in thailand and so he was
introduced to these nobles and he
actually uh one of them became his
teacher formerly
that man was um
bhikkhu
buddha gosigerne
who was actually the samdat sanga raja
the top monk in all of thailand and was
on that panel on that board of the
sangha decessor that's where he met
vikka buddhadasa
and so basically now the new question is
is vika buddhadasa going to be allowed
to continue to open the real teaching of
the buddha and let it out are we going
to keep it secret
within the
sangha
within the order of monks
the answer is
right
here i john paul
has basically given me the instructions
of the orders let's go out onto the
internet
and give the super mundane dhamma
let's let the cat out of the bag
westerners deserve the real teaching of
the buddha just like the thais do
that the westerners have only the
buddhist religion and the thais have for
many many centuries had both sides of it
both the inter the real teachings of the
buddha and actually the real teaching of
the buddha
be uh make monks who are really really
high quality human beings nobles uh
honorable people and because of that
they've generally become the abbots of
the various temples and watts in
thailand and for that reason
uh the nobility of the teaching of the
buddha has been spread around thailand
and so
uh it's time to bring this noble dhamma
out of
thailand
and laos because i know in fact that
that we're i've got a lot of stories
about this i don't want to waste
everybody's time but i it's it's really
interesting
how it takes one to know one how noble
actually talk with each other
so that it's uh easy to know
uh
and so
uh it's time that the noble dharma
come to the west and the best medium is
with
internet
so thank you very much for
uh having this top opportunity to at
least
make a brief introduction
to the actual teachings of the buddha
including how the april noble path and
eventually how anapanasanti
brings this state
of
mind this bright happy joyful
unconcerned state of mind
can be brought about and enjoyed by all
but we have to come out of the concept
of enlightenment because enlightenment
is way
up there for most people
an example of that is the word nabana
in the time of the buddha nirvana had
two uses one was that's what you do to
food
it's also done with animals
okay have you ever had a hot pizza come
right out of the oven you don't eat it
then it's too hot to eat you have to let
it nirvana you have to let it cool off
and when it gets just the right
temperature it's delicious
if it's too cold or it's too hot
then it's not delicious anymore
so
also animals
like a dog
dogs bark and bark and bark they're
territorial but the the dog can be
divided
so that it doesn't bark so much the dogs
can be trained
when a dog when a dog is not wild
anymore when he's just a domesticated
house pet
it's nibana
that's the way that we want to use the
word
okay
so anytime you're chilling out that's
nirvana just chill cool out
enjoy your life
at least enjoy the moment
that's what nirvana means
means to chill
and so now
let's give a working definition
something that can be used for the word
enlightenment because it's got
an actual value to it when you
understand
uh how to use the word
you see the word enlightenment actually
was part of the french revolution the
1700s the age of enlightenment which was
actually the dawning of the um
age
of science
and that's an important point the the
word has some value
and so let's look at enlightenment in
the sense of the primary word in it is
light
well we have daylight
we have turned the lights on
we have um the idea that we can
see things and know things better
with light
so by uh enlightenment the first kind
then is enlightenment which is knowledge
to gain knowledge to be able to see
things correctly to look
observe
note and to see
this is the first kind of enlightenment
the second kind of enlightenment is
not heavy
to lighten up
so if your mind is bright if it's
lightened up and you're taking a look at
what's going on in that moment you're
enlightened
in fact the zen talk about it all all
the time in the sense that the the new
zen student is working very hard wanting
something out of his meditation
and uh he's wanting to become
enlightened
and the old master says chill out boy
you're already enlightened
you're already enlightened why do you
want anything that you don't have
well you see
that kind of enlightenment is nothing
but a concept
and most people have the concept of
enlightenment
being light
lighten up that's enlightenment that's
all there is to it
beautiful
there was so much there that was
yummy
delicious
and
there was there were many points of
simplifying
to the masses that are critical and
there were moments to come in and play
but you were in flow on great trajectory
covering many different insightful areas
and
it was
it was quite nice
so let's revisit
let's let's revisit
so
what when asked the question what is
looking through your eyes what do you
say
i don't understand the question what
what is looking through your eyes
i don't understand the question
are you talking about an observer
what or who is looking through your eyes
um possibly the easiest way for people
to understand that is to talk a bit
about psychology
knowing that modern psychology when they
get it right
they're just merely rediscovering what
the buddha has already taught
so
within neuroscience
we talk about the brain
in regions
there's a lot of different bits and
pieces in those regions but primarily
the regions are the anterior cortex
the temporal cortex and the frontal lobe
the frontal cortex
these are the three parts of the brain
sigmund freud uh used that information
with his
ego super ego and id
but most people really never did figure
out what void was on about but one of
his students changed the language into
parent adult and child and that makes it
fairly easy to understand
so the the most primitive part of the
brain
that which is uh taking care of our uh
they call it the reptilian brain
because it's shaped like the drain of an
alligator and in fact everything that
you can do that an alligator can do is
done with that reptilian brain
walking around breathing blinking eyes
chewing food wagging our tail
heartbeats all of that kind of stuff is
done by the reptilian brain cause
anything that a uh reptile can do that
we can do we do the same part of the
brain that they do but there's a whole
lot of stuff that reptiles can't do
that dogs can do
like communication i mean the only thing
that alligators can do is either get out
of each other's way or confront each
other
but dogs have all kinds of um uh
communication systems
uh and so
the communication systems that human
have use that same part of the brain
which we could actually refer to then as
the parent or the superego
and that's where all of our old past
memories are stored as well as all of
our language and things
and now we get to the third part the
question that you ask which is the
frontal lobe
the part of our brain
the human brain that allows us to make
connections the observer
the the part that can do a mathematics
two plus two equals four and then we see
two plus two equals four again and again
and again and again we see you can see
those patterns it's the
and that observing part of the brain
uh actually takes the most energy
it's the
new kid on the block only humans have it
even chimpanzees don't have that part of
the brain
there's a lot of reasons why that they
think of why that
came about
but basically
you could say that it's because of
cooked food
that once we got fire and started
cooking food then a lot of the work that
we had to do with raw food is done by
the fire itself so that we can get much
more nourishment out of the food that we
eat
as well as the fact that we don't have
to have those huge jaw muscles that
baboons have
to chew it
so when the muscles get strong and
smaller that means that now we can use
that highly developed baboon neck area
for our own language this is how that
happened so because of cooked food we
have this huge huge uh super computer
up front this is what does the observing
but guess what that part of the brain is
often not in use
why because it does take a lot of work
that in fact in many cases
the um
the reptilian brain or the child is in
charge
that all night long
you continue to breathe
all night long the heart continues to
beat
why does that happen it happens because
of this reptilian brain
so the reptilian brain tends to be the
boss
but now there's the other part of the
brain called the super ego or the
temporal cortex or what is also called
the mammalian brain the mammal part of
the brain
that is all of our learned and stored
behavior and so if we are having a
dialogue a critical dialogue let us say
uh the guy is watching television he's
watching in fact he's watching youtube
and the thought comes you ought to be
meditating
that thought you ought to meditate
is coming out of the
super ego out of the parent ego state
he's heard it before you want to do this
you should do that in fact almost all of
the language that comes from the uh
uh this
uh temporal cortex or mammalian brain
actually
is
uh words that we've heard from our
parents that's why byrne calls it the
parent ego state that's all the shoulds
woods goods ought to be the way things
ought to be
uh the uh the rights rules rituals all
of that kind of stuff and so now the guy
is
watching video
watching youtube
and the thought comes you should be
meditating that thought comes out of
that critical mind that parent ego state
and the child
is the object of that and the child
inside says no i don't want to go
meditate right now
i want to watch a video
and while he's having that dialogue
several things are happening but
watching the video is not one of them
feeling marvelous and good is not one of
them because the child is being told
something to do that he doesn't want to
do and the parent is not getting what it
wants because the child is not obeying
orders
and so we're a crowd inside
most people don't even know about this
dialogue why because they're not
watching because the frontal cortex the
part that ought to be watching this kind
of stuff is not paying any attention
so basically sati
means to wake up or to put the frontal
cortex into gear
to give us some energy
one of the ways of giving it some energy
is by taking a deep breath this is why
the buddha talks about it as on upon
asati in breathing and out breathing and
uh
to be mindful of this in the sense of
uh
when we say sati
or mindfulness of breathing
what we're really meaning is is that we
have to take control of the breathing
if we do not control the breathing then
the mind will just wander right away
from it because the mind's got no skin
in the game it's got no attachment to it
so when you say watch the breath
people don't watch it very long and the
mind wanders away
but if you start to control the breath
in the sense of breathing in long
that long deep in breathing will
actually help put the mind in gear it'll
give it the oxygen it needs
and also the long deep out breath
will help rid the body of carbon dioxide
and so breathing is a major part of
one's right effort to take the effort to
actually start breathing well
and by doing so we're paying attention
to the breathing which means that on the
in-breath we remember to take a long
deep in
and on the out breath remember to take a
long deep out breath
so every breath that you take on an in
and out cycle means that you have two
points of psyche that's the skill that
we want to develop is to develop the
breath
develop the remembering to be in the
present moment
[Music]
you're in this present moment
the way that you can be in this present
moment is by having that frontal cortex
this part of the brain
in operation
get it working get it going and when
it's working and going then it can start
paying attention to all of these
critical thoughts that are coming out of
the parent ego state out of the
mammalian brain
pay attention to it
and not only that but we can see how the
child reacts to it
so
if
watching the video watching youtube and
the thought comes you ought to be
meditating and the guy is there for it
he'll hear that thought and says yeah
boy
let's do that and so we take a deep
breath
and then the answer is i am meditating
but that takes waking up
you wake up to actually take that deep
breath and be meditating right now
you don't have to put to turn the tv off
or the uh the youtube off and then go
sit down to meditate you can take a
meditation breath moment right now
because you remembered to
but that also answers your question
about what is the observer the observer
is that which we're wanting to put into
gear
so that you can actually start observing
that's right noble
you see uh the right noble view is
actually viewing from the frontal cortex
ordinary right view
has already defined what is right and is
not doing anymore he's just repeating
concepts
the right noble view is to really look
use that frontal cortex
open your eyes your mind's eye and pay
attention to what's going on
and one of the things that you begin to
see is that hey you can feel the way you
want to feel
all our lives we've spent our whole life
talking ourselves into feeling bad
because of that parent ego state in our
own minds plus the language of the
parents and uh
teachers and all that we had when we
were kids
and so
that's the normal world that we live in
is in a dialogue between the parent the
child and the parent and the child but
when we wake up that means now we're
putting that frontal cortex into gear
and the frontal cortex now becomes the
boss
and the boss is going to tell the front
of the uh uh
the talking mind the verbal part
the uh
super ego
the parent
to stop being critical
and being a critical parent start
nurturing instead
and so we begin to nurture ourselves
there there now everything's okay
not a worry in the world there are no
dangers there's no alligators there's no
crocodiles
everything is okay no place to go
nothing to do
the spring comes and the grass
goes all by itself
you don't have to do anything
everything's okay
now that's a better meditation
than sitting in front of the uh youtube
saying you want to meditate not now i
don't want to but you ought to go
meditate
so in that regard
the parent is confused because he thinks
that meditation means you got to go do
something
real meditation means that you can stop
doing right now
yippee
[Music]
great so let's do a recap on some of the
core
essence
so
what we can
some one of the ways that we can simply
express
what is being communicated
is that
there's what appears to be
this
sun
which is all
and then there appears to be clouds
and the whole game
is to
cut through the clouds and remember
oneself as the sun that is the all
and
the core essence of how to cut through
clouds
has a lot of its roots in dependent
origination and has a lot of its roots
in on upon the sati
so
when you become aware
of discursive thinking from concept to
idea to separate form to separate person
to separate shape
to separate perception or sensation or
object or experience etc
you recognize that all of that
is appearing
and disappearing
like clouds but what remains is
something
that's indescribable
and that does not have identity
there is not
an atlas
character that that atlas character has
been
a dream of the intelligence in its play
with itself
and so now we're really at like the core
essence which is turning inward on one's
own
source of perception itself
going all the way to one source of
perception and wondering self-inquiry
who am i what is this that is perceiving
and also
is this perceiving
sporadic discursive thought
or is this perceiving from the heart or
as you indicated in
neuroscience prefrontally is this
is this perceiving from love is this
perceiving from wholeness is this
perceiving from unity from
non-separation from emptiness and from
infinity and in doing that inquiry
perpetually you cut through those clouds
you remember yourself as this one
infinite sun
and you see that everywhere that becomes
your reality that becomes this radiant
enlightenment
and then
and then all that's left is just to
serve creation honorably
lovingly
in a non-attached way
to maximize prosperity abundance
playfulness
architectures that serve the prosperity
of all
and this is the essence in a small recap
of what we've
been sharing
and it's really nice because a lot of
what damarato speaks about here is also
it's also available
and i'll pull it up so that our audience
can see
it's available right here on his channel
and the links in the bio below also if
you would like to
to go and click and and look through
but the youtube channel has lots and
lots of content on it
and lots of
just simple
explanations
of what we've been discussing
and he's also
very open to fielding
inquiry as well
so people can just reach out
and they can hop on a skype call that's
right
yes
yeah
great
and that info is in the uh i believe in
the about section
you can find uh some of the contact
information
generally the descriptions have a link
also every every video that has a
description we'll have a link down in
the description
okay
um let's go back and visit a couple of
things that you said
the first thing to visit is
you use the word perception
and within the context of the teacher
simon potter there is actually a
specific definition for it
and that you're using it something a
little bit differently
and so i would
point that out but let's get back to the
point about the sun and the clouds
and that you mentioned that everything
is arising and passing away
everything is arising and passing away
that a thought does not last very long
only about a tenth of a second maybe uh
uh a fifth of a second something like
that
but then it
comes again
things arise and they pass away they
arise and they pass away they arise and
they pass away a lot of us have the idea
that our lives are dc to where in fact
our lives are ac everything is up and
down
everything arises and passes away
each cloud that comes passes away on its
own
but guess what the sun also arises and
passes away everything is temporary
there's no you there's no sun there's no
anything that's permanent
everything is temporary
which means that everything is in motion
everything is in flux
uh and the whole concept of self
especially from this issue of the um the
christian ideal of the soul
is something that's really permanent
this is so permanent that we talk about
it in the sense of everlasting
or eternalism
but in fact everything
is temporary
everything is temporary something is new
i don't know what that is but it's
something new
is that a back scratcher
yeah it's this massager it's so good ah
okay
yeah please continue you're on a great
point
okay well this point about a nietzsche
everything is in flux basically the way
that our um
the anatomy works
is is that it's hard to pay attention to
the things that are not moving
and and see things that are moving
for instance you can look at something
or you can just look and have what we
call gazing
so let us say that you were gazing on
the floor and all you kind of see is
generalized floor but if you see an ant
or a tick or some small animal crawling
on the floor
then that tick
will get your attention
because we see the movement
all right
generally then when we see something
happen that catches our attention
and
uh it brings up perhaps doubts
curiosities uncertainties what is that
is it dangerous and when we have the
thought that it might be dangerous
that's when the selfishness comes in
trying to protect
the
organism from the tick or getting bit by
the ant or whatever
and so basically what we're looking at
here is that
we have this trilocona
or the three characteristics anicha duca
or anata
is not a sequence of events but it's
rather a choice that we have
the choice is is that whenever any event
happens when everything happens in the
sense of a change
that we can either choose
to be selfish
or not about it
if we choose to be selfish then that's
going to lead to dukkha
it may in fact end the ant's life we'll
step on it or something
and so initia
means that uh it's an opportunity
whenever we see something change
the opportunity is either dukkha or
anata
in other words when we see something
change we can say to ourselves or
that ant is not my aunt
or that tick is not my tick
not my business not my problem
if we say that that tick on the floor
that i just saw calling is my tick
now
that's the selfishness that's going to
lead to dukkha
if there is no
selfishness then
then the tick is going to be okay i'm
i'm okay
but if i claim that that tick is my tick
or that i feel danger because of that
tick on the floor then more than likely
the ticks won't get killed
why because i'm trying to protect myself
from the danger of getting bit by that
tick
but when it's not my tick i got no
problem
some people will get so upset with ticks
that they go around killing ticks all
the time it becomes their business of
doing nothing but going around killing
ticks
or ants or whatever your thing is
where in fact
the ticks are not dangerous
when we recognize that things that
change are not dangerous
then we don't have to be selfish about
them and if we're not selfish then
there's no duca
this is what is the teaching of the
trilocona
when anesha happens when something
changes you've got a choice
are you going to be selfish about it and
try to own it or are you going to just
leave it alone not yours not mine none
of my business
the spring comes and the grass grows all
by itself not my grass
so biker buddhadasa had a phrase like
that
that he says that this is a very common
phrase in the sutras
and it and it uh translates into english
as
nothing is worth clinging to
as i me or mine
that in fact it's really hard to cling
to something without a concept of i mean
mine
that does the clinging
you can think of it like this notice
that the arm
and now if this arm is clinging to it if
i'm clinging here that means that the
arm clinging has to have a cling ore
to it
that's the part that's the actual uh
creation of the cell
is that which comes into play in order
to do the clinging
if we're not clinging then there's no
salt
another way of saying that this is the
self is the bucket in which we carry our
duka
if there is no bucket
then we're not going to be carrying much
gluco the bigger the cell
the bigger the duka or the itself the
bigger the bucket the bigger
uh
area we have for carrying a bunch of
suffering in
a bunch of dukkha
so this is the way to understand the
trilocana is that you've got a choice
you're either going to be selfish
and have dukkha or you can be out of it
not your business
no fixation on anything that arises
including the person the costume
decrease the surface area for attack
by emptying out your bucket of self
all of your and throwing out the bucket
and throwing out the bucket
the bucket's unnecessary
the only reason we have that bucket
there is because we think we need it
for protection
from dangers
and when there is no danger there's
nothing to be afraid of
this is why the buddha is really big on
fearlessness
if we're not afraid then we don't need
the protection
so just remembering that really you got
no problems everything is all right
everything's okay
no place to go nothing to do
everything's all right
everything's all right
everything's fine
no place to go nothing to do the spring
comes the grass goes by itself
and so all then we have left to do is
just merely relax
so instead of thinking about a cloud
and the sun and getting the clouds out
of the way so that you can
uh be the sun
a better thing a better way to look at
it is that i don't care about clouds i'm
too busy having fun
and when i have thoughts of not having
fun i can see those and i can throw them
out and said never mind
yeah
and then there's the
patterns of conditioning that emerge
while the claim of
i'm just having fun
and then they're suffering and so
the
turn
to cut through said egoic solidity
is
inevitable because the drill sergeant of
awakening comes and that's suffering
dukkha
and you may as well turn in
and another one of is just not wanting
to
be the void
not wanting to be shunyata not wanting
to be emptiness
yeah well look we're in our society
we're taught to be something
yeah this is it this is this is probably
the biggest thing is that uh the
promulgation of
of the individuated expression which is
fine and it's and it's also beautiful
because
it's it's cool to
paint what you're resonating with to
make music with what you're resonating
with to investigate some sort of science
to make a regenerative energy system for
the planet you know cool stuff cool
stuff but do you know who you are do you
know what you are first and foremost do
you
matter
that's in fact one of the questions that
the buddha says is irrelevant not only
is it irrelevant
but it is dark
that he talks about it in suture number
two in the sabah asa basuta in the sense
of what is worth paying attention to
and who am i and what was i in the past
and what i will become and all of those
kind of questions wind up
giving us a bunch of
issues to solve
by saying this and i'm not that but i
want to be that now i've got work to do
to go do that and all of this kind of
stuff
am i
and not only that but here's a really
big important point and that is is that
every human being is a moving target
today you can write down all of the
characteristics of who you are
and then tomorrow you go and do the same
thing and over time you'll see that that
list changes that in fact by the time
you get to the end of the list you may
want to go scratch out some of the items
on the front of the list
and change it
because you're constantly changing
sometimes you feel like a nut and
sometimes you don't
so you can't define who you are because
you're in the constant state of flux
so asking yourself questions about who
am i is bound
to become confusing
a much better thing to pay attention to
[Music]
would be and it's stated like this in
the in the sutras that things that are
worthy of your attention would be
this is suffering
this is the cause of suffering
this is what is going to not be
suffering and this is the path that
leads to the end of suffering now that
whole thing is talked about in the sense
of this present moment
this is dukkha
by observing and seeing
instead of asking myself questions who
am i
look at the question of where is the
dukkha
where is the dissatisfactions
what are the causes of my
dissatisfaction the causes are my
critical thoughts
what are my critical thoughts about who
am i
and when i stop that critical thinking
and recognizing and having critical
thinking about who am i
is just dukkha i can stop and relax
and so paying attention to the four
noble truths in great detail and really
looking at them and especially in the
sense of the way that i've been talking
about the april noble path
that we come up the position of
personality view we get over who am i
we're no longer concerned with who am i
who am i is not important
and that we often identify ourselves as
who am i with the language of society
we identify with ourselves when i when i
say
just to be clear when i say who am i i'm
talking about ramana maharshi
self-inquiry that's all i'm talking
about okay i'm not i'm not talking i'm
not talking about the what is this
individual's
goals in the world and needs needs for
fixation and needs for cravings and
likes and dislikes not talking about
that
i'm talking about the moth turning
inward onto the flame and dissolving
i i don't recommend that
i don't i don't recommend uh
flawless
moths associating with the fire at all
they ought to go stay in the dark and
stay safe
those those fires are dangerous for moss
yeah well that's what we're talking
about with the piercing through the
clouds to recognize yourself as the sun
and if
and if we're not if we're not able to
simultaneously be non-dualistic while
also being dualistic then
then that's also a a spiritual
flavor that society has taken on that is
not simultaneous
and so
it really needs its simultaneity we need
to both be able to see that this is
already an absolute free ineffable
perfection
eternal and yet also
okay
and yet also simultaneously see
that
if there is an arising of some sort of
pattern of conditioning of i feel
unworthy and i need to do this or that
whatever that there is some sort of turn
to cut through those clouds of
conditioning and to feel more whole and
to feel like you already are it and so
this is just the simultaneity there
but not with a capital i yet
just
this is it
yeah
that is it's a pretty big it
and a really really small piece of it
but at least we fit in
at least we're comfortable
yeah if we don't have to um fit into
society we have to fit into reality
and society doesn't fit into reality
very well
that in fact is most people use society
to define who they are
that i'm only me
in relationship to something else
like i'm an engineer or i'm a garbage
collector or i'm a doctor or
something like that so we often define
ourselves with our profession or we
define ourselves with our hobby or we
define ourselves with our political
interest
but without any of those kind of
concepts
it's really hard to define who you are
and that's not even an irrelevant thing
anyway what's relevant according to the
teachings of the duke of the buddha is
dukkha duke naroda
now a lot of people think of dukkha
naroda as a long-term goal takes years
and years and years they see it like
this and in fact they as a meditator
they practice dukkha do kaduka i see
dukkha i'm in examining dukkha i can see
dukkha do kaduka everywhere
and that's not
that's not a duke that's just a bug
uh
so
the real point is is that when we see
duka duke and erota we can see it
immediately
if we can see the duka we can sidestep
it an example of that is the farmer who
is going to go see his cows
on the other side of the pasture if he
keeps his eye on those cows and knows
where he's going and watches
those cows to make sure that they're
there and he's got his gold planned and
he goes right to them
when he gets there he's going to be
covered in [ __ ]
cow shed
cow pies
because he's not worried watching where
he's going he's too interested in
his target
real duka duka naroda means watch every
step
and if you see a cow pie don't step in
it right now that's dukkha avoid it
immediately
so when we take that analogy out of the
cow pasture and put it into the mind and
recognize that there's all kinds of uh
cow pies to step in
past
future this place over there that place
yonder everywhere is different but all
of them are cow pies
to step in
or we can choose to to uh
be careful about what thoughts we have
so that we can always step on firm solid
clean ground
these are the hopes and thoughts so you
can say that the uh the
pasture is covered with cow pies but not
every
inch of land is covered with cow pie
they're just all over the place
so you can also think of your mind that
way that there's plenty of wholesome
thoughts to have but there's also plenty
of hopes of unhold some thoughts to
avoid
one step at a time one thought at a time
this is really the teaching of the
buddha is dukkha naroda
right now
do it right now
don't say oh if i meditate for 10 000
hours then the common machine will come
in with the shaktipot and make me happy
no your happiness is right here right
now
your duke of naroda is right now
not 10 15 years 100 000 hours of
meditation from now it's right this very
minute
that's the teaching duka duka narota
right here right now
we've removed the personality view
when we do that when we recognize that
who i am and the definitions of who i am
is completely irrelevant
what's relevant is am i enjoying this
moment
no matter what kind of clothes i'm
wearing are mental clothes i'm wearing
so not concerned with who i am just
concerned with this very moment is a
pleasant moment
just awake presence just eternity
awake present
well as
often as you like
as often as you can remember
our society has words built into it that
as i said comes out of the history that
leaves us with words like always or all
the time
and this is bound to get into that
critical parent thinking that you ought
to be doing it all the time
rather than nurturing like oh i'm glad
you did it now
so all the time is actually
a danger word we should put that on our
don't do list
and stop talking about doing it all the
time and just do it when you remember to
do it
that's the skill that we're developing
psyche
and when that satie becomes the skill
that is unremitting what do i mean by
unremitting means like this
that this is a drum and this is the
mallet for the drum
is this the way to beat a drum watch
what what's what we're doing get it on
the screen okay and then this this is
the way that most people play their drum
not very musical is it
but at least i'm playing it all the time
sati is not like that sati is much more
like this
that sati
unremitting like the energizer bunny
beat come back come back okay like anna
panasati mindful of this in-breath be
mindful that this is a long in-breath be
mindful that this is a long out
breath in this present moment
be here now
remember to be here now
that's the real teaching of the buddha
and we don't do it with the idea of all
the time because if you say you got to
do it all the time and then you don't do
it all the time you'll feel bad
some of the time
but if you practice correctly then every
time you remember you wind up feeling
really good
because i remember to wake up to gladden
up
but many people will have the idea that
when they do wake up
then they feel bad
because they were already feeling bad
before they woke up
and when they do wake up they wake up to
the point only to say oh i'm not
watching the breath
then poor me
my my
mind is a monkey mind i can't think
right and so people go right down into
the into the garbage into the sewer
when they had just a little bit of saute
but we need to have a big amount of
satin not just decided to wake up and
and then continue feeling bad but to
wake up completely and to come out of it
and to gladden the mind
and to be here now fully awake
can you wake up completely that's the
sighting and it's a skill again to be
developed
over and over again we practice but you
can do it over and over again because
you've got a breath
this in and out and in and out over and
over and over again
but if you thought that we were
breathing all the time that means that
you're breathing and breathing and
breathing and breathing how long is this
in-breath going to be if you continue to
breathe him forever and ever no we're
not going to do that we're going to have
this
in and out and up and down and back and
forth because that's reality everything
is in plucks
and so your
mindfulness will also be in flux
develop it so that it keeps coming back
it keeps coming back and keeps coming
back
but don't make it stay there because
that's hard to do that's a skill a
different kind of skill to build
so that's my little blurb about uh
always and forevers and uh
all day long
kind of like
since we're at the time of the olympics
it's kind of like the olympics of
consciousness with these contemplative
fitness athletes
that are able to sustain
said awake presence
for 24 hours a day
and that's
but even olympic champions don't do it
24 hours a day
they need to do it
the uh
the girl who's going to twirl through
the air and land on her feet she only
needs that mindfulness when she's
getting ready to run when she's jumping
when she's twirling and when she's
landing after she does her olympic thing
she can go home and have a pity party
especially
yeah and then if a pity party is the way
that the creation wants to express
itself then go for it as whatever
appearance it's all equanimous so
beauty
yeah really seems like this boiling down
to this eternal awake presence
without an actual identity
without uh
preferences
not eternal
and nature remembering everything
nothing is eternal
nothing is
except source
pardon except source or the emptiness
the dharmakaya
that which comprehends everything
that's a good magical thinking isn't it
and we don't even need any of that
there's nothing eternal
that in fact anything that was eternal
you could call that with eternal kind of
language
an example of something eternal would be
a soul
or a self
in the teaching of the buddha you've
heard about uh
anata another way that's a little more
complex that they talk about it and that
is sabae sankata
anitra
sabe
um
sankara
duka
sabe
damma anata now what does that mean and
why is there a change to it
sankara actually means
compounded things things that are stuck
together
like
oxygen
and hydrogen are stuck together to make
water
but that hydrogen and that oxygen can be
separated they are not permanently and
forever attached together
they're not eternal
the same thing is true then with all
kinds of things
that everything that is uh comes
together
will fall apart everything that's a
nietzsche will change everything that is
are changed to the point of coming
together will then change to fall apart
everything that arises will pass away
del morato and this is exactly why we're
at the subject now which is the question
that i asked you about what is looking
that which looks
that very source
through all of the anisha
through all of it
that which comprehends all of the
impermanence
let's change that from all you're you're
doing a whole lot of superlatives let's
go back to
that which can
on
occasion see
this dukkha rather than that which all
sees all duca because
there's nothing that sees all of it
there's only
you who can see this one
and so that gets back then to the point
that i was going in the law comprehends
itself
the all comprehends itself
and the all is both
absolute flame
of anisha of impromptu i know about the
all the all that you're talking about is
the concept
well there's a little bit more of it in
direct experience than concept
but direct experience has to do with how
good you feel
how good you feel is the way that you
feel
and maybe the thoughts that you were
having made you feel that way but that
doesn't mean the thoughts that you were
having that made you feel that way the
thoughts are real they're just thoughts
so you can have thoughts about the all
and feel really good about the all but
then when you have thoughts about uh all
minus something then you can have
different feelings
that in fact here's the point that uh we
can come to with this and that is is
that feelings
are not associated or caused by the all
feelings are caused by
thoughts
that they're interrelated
and so you can have thoughts about all
and feel a certain way and say that's
the all but you can have thoughts about
uh an ice cream sundae feel that same
way
and start a religion around ice cream
sundays
let's hone in on exactly the essence of
what is being played with because it's
uh it's fascinating so
that which comprehends infinite creation
that
is source and that is not a concept
wait a minute let's go back say that
first line again that
that which comprehends infinity
there is no infinity infinity is a
concept
well this is beautiful that there is
something that we've explored that we uh
um
that we feel there's something to play
with because
infinity is a direct realization it's
not a
concept no it's only a concept
and the direct realization that you're
talking about is free of the concepts
but what you really like what you really
want is that feeling
that
wow
that some people have that feeling when
they have the thought of merging
with y'all it's not a waha or a wow at
all it's actually very equanimous it's
just knowing oneself as the very empty
infinitude that this is
and knowing oneself as that and not as
the character that's appearing on this
stage
and that's what is meant by this one
here's the question and are you
satisfied with that or not
of course i am it's beautiful
all right well now let's start looking
then at the satisfaction and then stop
looking at the soil
it just is
it's not something that gives me elation
it's just something that is and when you
recognize
yourself as that which
is and isn't
that
which is nothing being everything
that is the end game
that's what appears to be the end game
and that's
just what it is
you still feel lousy and have a pity
party then what's the point of having
that end game yeah yeah there's no
feeling lousy or a pity party
well
it's just
it's just when you're in the shower and
you're
you
are feeling the awake presence
in the shower and then for a moment you
go into discursive thought
and then you return back to the awake
presence it's just what's up it's just
what's appearing there's no judgment
there's no hatred there's no ill will
against oneself that's it it's just that
i've got that that's what we're playing
with you can do that without having
concepts of the all
the all is optional in there
well yeah so there's like a night
there's an idea you can't do it without
having thoughts of the all and other
people can in fact get themselves into a
really really good state and they don't
have to think about the all at all
yeah but when you live inside of your
skin
um you're
always going to have conditioning is
without a doubt when you live inside of
your skin even if you tag
your life as awake presence
but living inside of your skin you're
never going to identify as the universe
and you're never going to identify as
emptiness because you're stuck inside of
your skin
why would i want to identify with the
universe
that's just a conceptualization and for
most people emptiness is a
conceptualization
that i can just sit here and do nothing
and that's empty enough
i'll give you an example
don't want to let it last too long
because we're on the screen here
but
you don't need an all
to be empty that kind of is almost
contradictory in our language so so this
this
is
infinity expressing itself i
just there's no other way that i've been
able to express that statement
here's here's actually an issue
the definition of words
is an issue between the two of us
because i have
actually i work really hard to make sure
that we define the words correctly and
you're using the word infinity
in a way that i understand
um mathematically i'm been in too much
mathematics
it's just pure it's just pure
potentiality is another way to say it
okay potentiality is one thing but
infinity doesn't exist
doesn't exist anywhere
for instance grains of sand
is finite it's a large number but it's
finite
how about the number of galaxies is very
large but it's finite there's only so
many of them
it may take you forever and forever and
forever is another word to find it but
uh the end of it and count all the
galaxies
but there's only a certain number of
them there we just don't know what that
is
there's also the theory of large numbers
really where the word in the idea of
infinity came from was from division by
zero
yeah that's the nature of reality is
that
that's the nature of reality is
something that is infinite that which is
infinite
no that's the nature
it doesn't exist
that it's the imperfect concept
and we do not need the concept of
infinity to feel really good and a lot
of people will have the concept infinity
and feel really bad about it
some will feel confused some will feel
angry
so it's not the concept of infinity or
even thoughts about infinity that make
you feel really good
so you think if it's not infinite that
means that you think there is an end to
impermanence
um
the buddha had four imponderables
one of the imponderables is how did
things get started
another imponderable
and i i don't know why they use the word
imponderable
uh i they i think that's what he's
talking about is it's not worth thinking
about
but one imponderable uh and in fact the
one that you're asking about
is
what are the results of actions
the buddha says that that's not
ponderable
in other words you will not figure out
what's the end of things or what are the
results
another uh imponderable is
what is the human mind capable of and
how far it will go
and the fourth imponderable is what
happens
after one dies
the most specific of what happens to a
buddha after the buddha dies
what happens the answer to that is not
only do we not know but we don't even
care the imponderables are um
imponderable
not because we can't figure it out it's
because it's not worth figuring it out
and so you actually you just asked a
question
that's kind of irrelevant it's not
really worth figuring out who cares
what's going to happen way off into the
future the question is can you enjoy
this present moment
who cares about how things got started
way back in the past
because what because what in what
assists
oneself
with
enjoyment of being awake and being
present is knowing their true nature as
infinity as emptiness
that's what i said the concept you can
be completely awake and not have that
concept of the thought
yeah it's free while you're having that
context
after after viewing enough patterns
though of
behavior and action conditioning
that the less the less
that
one has bathed in emptiness and infinity
the more conditioning is present which
means there's more discursive thinking
which means there's more unworthiness
which means there's more separation
and so this game of recognizing oneself
as this boundless infinite intelligence
which is what this is and that it will
eternally be
means that there's no end to
impermanence which is what i was trying
to point at
and so if you think that there is an end
to impermanence that would be something
that's finite but infinity
and impermanence also go hand in hand
let's go this way
there are six answers
to every yes and no question
yes and no questions have six answers
okay
one answer would be yes it's true
another answer would be no it's not true
another answer would be it's neither one
it's not a and it's not b it's c
the other possibility is that it's both
okay
so we've gotten four let's use an
example of
you've got black on one side and white
on the other why why don't we just use
the example of infinity infinity or
permanence and impermanence because
that's what we're talking about
well that actually we've gotten four and
that uh is a
just forget about those four and go to
number five number five is i don't know
and number six is that it's irrelevant
to this present moment so irrelevant so
five is myth three five is mystery and
six is irrelevance
cool
cool so
all of these play into the equation
which is infinite finite permanent
impermanent mystery and irrelevant they
all play into the equation
all right okay
and so that's it it's irrelevant i don't
care what's going to happen after that
the only thing that's interesting is
right now
yeah this dance
into the future is a concept it's not
here
this dance right now
that's right life is not a march it's a
waltz this is it this is all we've got
let's just have a ball
[Music]
who cares about whether things are
infinite or not that's not my job
not my business
but i understand that a lot of religious
stuff
is trying to be
uh talked about through concepts that in
fact i can't even talk to you without
using concepts
but we have to know the distinction
between what is conceptualized
and what is real and it's really hard
for me to talk about
real
that i talk about it in concepts to
invite
the people
my friends
to experience
the direct reality without needing
concepts about alls and infinities and
bigness and
becoming one with all
make me one with all and i all i got was
a hot dog
who's a good hot dog enjoy
for the hot dog who needs the all
you know that joke don't you the joke is
is that the dalai lama went to the u.n
and while he was there he saw a hot dog
vendor out on the streets of new york
and he walks up to the hot dog vendor
and says
make me one with everything
and all he got was a hot dog
[Music]
but the daily llama knows how to enjoy a
hot dog
wow
so can coming out of our concepts
that we talked about very early in our
talk
coming out of the concepts means coming
out of the past and out of the future
and for you infinity is something off
into the future
it's not right here now i don't have an
infiniti i've got a i've got a
flashlight
i've got a stick but i don't have any
infiniti here
[Music]
you're like the grand theft auto
character that's inside of the finite
game that can't prove that it's
a ps5 playing infinite games and i don't
care
those things are irrelevant
just like other things are irrelevant
one thing that's completely irrelevant
is does god exist or not
that's you
you are it and it's an emptiness being
infinity that's what it is that's a
concept also
okay
the question is is if i if i have that
concept do i feel like that or do i have
that concept and want to feel like that
it's just play
precisely precisely and if we understand
that it's played then we can play if we
under if we think that these concepts
are not toys to play with but are real
things then we want them
and now we're wanting things that we
don't have
like make me one with everything is a
plea that says i am not good enough
right now
and if you make me one with everything
then i will be good enough
and actually all we have to do is change
the attitude oh i'm good enough now i
don't need to be one with everything
you're already everything appearing like
a character
yeah you're already everything you got
you already everything you need all you
have to do is just enjoy your life be
happy
don't worry be happy
or like the zen say you're already
enlightened
you don't have to warn anything you're
okay
this is so fun
if you let it be a lot of people can be
here and argue and get hot under the
collar and be angry and all of that kind
of stuff there's no equanimity then
there's no equanimity
there's no awake presence
well that's because they want
they want their concepts
instead of just recognizing that it's a
concept that's all it is
just the dance just the play that's so
nice everything is all right everything
is fine
see that's that's probably the essence
of the yeah
like like you pointed out several times
it's just what is
is already the dance is already the play
it's already perfection
and breathe
enjoy your hot dog
dance a bit
yeah yeah
and if you feel separation if you feel
these
malevolences arising just inquire
into
awake presence into oneness just inquire
into
wholeness rather than separation
the child like innocence be here now
everything is all right
and you can have that childlike
innocence when you're telling yourselves
nurturing thoughts
everything's all right everything's fine
you're a good boy
everything's good
congratulations on taking this breath
beautiful
beautiful
thank you thanks samurato thank you
thank you
thank you thank you
so sweet i look forward to potentially
more explorations together
really nice really nice
i enjoy this has been a lot of fun
good to hear
good to hear
and thanks everyone
yeah everything's good everything's all
right everything's perfect
as it is
amen amen
amen
yeah
thanks everybody
thanks guys thanks for tuning in we know
you've got many of you have been
watching for the entirety of the stream
we're really grateful for you guys thank
you for watching
we would love for you to leave a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
let us know how you feel
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet also
share the video with other people that
you feel like this would positively
influence and go and subscribe also to
don morato's channel the links in the
bio below it's got lots of great content
on there
very fun playful
of course
yes yes yeah above it all
just above it all
yes in a way we're you you've got
infinity that's big stuff but i'm even
above that but
[Laughter]
i'm just this lotus flower
exactly
well i'm too a
[Laughter]
[Music]
sometimes we feel like we're nuts and
sometimes
we don't sometimes we feel like a nut
sometimes we don't
watch closely now
ooh great yeah wholeness and separation
wholeness don't feel like a nut
separation we feel nuts
[Laughter]
oh great okay beautiful thank you again
um i'll end the studio um but you and i
stay in the room and i'll just end the
stream okay
okay
all right